hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
clinical validation of the eliminatem hr
hpv assay i am michelle ashton of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths
and brought to you by abbott global
scientific affairs
to learn more visit molecular.abbott.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now present today's speaker
anya osterbank
analyst in laboratory biomedicine
institute of microbiology and immunology
faculty of medicine at the university of
ljubljana slovenia
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen anya you may
now begin your presentation welcome
hello my name is annie ostervink
valenciak and i will present
today clinical validation of the
identity m
high risk hpv essay
so this is my disclosures client
and i would like to start with the
status
of hpv tests that are
on the global market in 2020
so our research group has been
performing the inventory of
hpv essays since 2010
and as you can see in the last decade
the number of hpv assets
available on on the global market has
been increasing dramatically
so in our first inventory in 2010
we have identified 70 hpv essays
and this year we have identified almost
more than 250 hpv tests
so what is the problem the problem is
that we have
shown that more almost 60 percent
of the hpv tests that are currently
present
are without any single peer-reviewed
publication
even higher percentage more than 80 of
hiv tests
are without published analytical and or
clinical evaluation
in the peer-reviewed literature
um and the most concerning thing is that
over 90
of the hpv tests is not evaluated
according to the standards that are
agreed
in hpv community so
we urge to the hpv test manufacturers to
perform
the evaluation of hiv tests that are
daily used in clinical practices
so at the moment we still have the
guidelines from 2009
from myers group and these are the
guidelines for the hpv
that are used in clinical practice and
basically there are three three items
in these guidelines that must be met so
hpv essays
can be safely used in the primary hpv
screening
so the first one is about clinical
sensitivity for cn2 plus
the second is clinical specificity that
should be
non-inferior to the standard comparator
which can be
either hybrid capture 2 or gp5 plus 6
plus
and the last one is about the
performance
and robustness of hp tests and it's
regarding the
intra-laboratory reproducibility and
inter-laboratory agreement
so the study that i'm gonna present in
the first
part of my talk is about slovenian hpv
prevalence study
so the first screening round was
performed in 2009
to 2010 and
it was performed in slovenia so slovenia
is a relatively
small european country we have about
2 million of people living in slovenia
and as you can see we are right in the
middle of the europe
and in we have quite effective
nationally organized
cervical cancer screening program with
high coverage
over 70 percent and
in addition to that we also have hpv
vaccination that is integrated into
national immunization program it's free
of charge it's school based
but unfortunately we have
relatively low appliance we have about
45 to 55 coverage and
we are hoping that this will rise
so the gynecologists that were
included in our study are from all over
the country and
we have in enrolled four thousand and
four hundred women that were aged 20 to
64
and who were attending their routine pop
screening
so the sample is representative for our
population and we have collected
the cervical samples into tin prep
medium
and they were uh eliquided and stored
at -80 upon arrival in the laboratory
so beside the samples for hpv testing
we have also performed conventional
cytology
this is standard of care in slovenia
and also the colposcopy and biopsy was
performed
according to standard of care in
slovenia which is
asco's high or worse psychology
however irrespective of the cytology
result
all women that were hpv 16 or hpv 18
positive were also invited to
the colposcopy so
entire cohort was tested with
four different hpv essays and the first
one was hybrid capture two from kaijin
uh the second one was real time from
abbott and also the new alienity that we
are discussing today
and the last one was kobas from roche
and we have used the 4800
platform so the second screening round
of our study was performed three years
later
and it lasted from 2012 and
till 2014
and in this second screening round we
were able to
enroll three thousand and eight eight
hundred women
and this cohort was tested using
real time and elinity alone
so this is a study timeline that shows
the
identification of the cn2 class cases i
will
just quickly go through it
so in the first screening round we have
identified 68
cn2 plus cases and in the second
screening round
we have identified 36 ciento plus cases
so a little more than 100 of cn2
cases were identified in both
screening rounds and the study is still
ongoing
we are following women through national
data registry
and we are collecting data about
psychology and histology result
so i will start with the prevalence
um that was assessed using alinity in
the first screening round
so as you can see and as you can as we
expected
the highest burden of hpv prevalence
was among the youngest in the highest in
the age group 20 to 24
and also 25 to 29
but what we also uh but
we can also see from this graph we can
see that
when we hope this is going to be soon
when slovenia switched to hpv primary
screening
hopefully in the next next years
we uh we will probably start
hpv primary screening from age 35
because the prevalence is just too high
in in
in women that are younger than that
also if we uh plot on the same graph the
prevalence from the second screening
ground shown here in orange we can see
that the prevalence
is basically the same through the
age groups and there are no statistical
significant differences
between the prevalence in the first and
the
second screening round
we have also done the sub analysis
for the prevalence according to the
cytology result
so we have taken women that had normal
cytology
and then the the rest were asco's group
also group and hysil group and
we can see very clearly that the
prevalence
for hpv infection is
corresponding to the cytology severity
so the the the more severe psychology is
the higher the higher the prevalence is
so the highest prevalence
were was in high seal almost 85 percent
i would like to show you also the
prevalence uh according to cytology for
all of the five channels of alinity
so alinity sa is
um has the potential for expanded
genotyping
and we can identify hpv 16
hpv 18 and hbv 45
separately and then we have two channels
channel a
and channel b in channel a we have hv
types
31 33 52 and 58
in the channel b are the other seven hpv
types
are included and what is interesting
here
is that in all the other groups
the hbo prevalence is rising
and it's corresponding to cytology
severity except in except
in the last group so channel b ovalinity
where we can see that the prevalence
for hpv infection of
channel b is declined significantly
in the group of women that had high cell
cytology
so this was the first clue for the hpv
triage
but we're gonna uh talk a bit more in
in risk in the next part of my
talk so i will start with the
evaluation of identity according to
meijer guidelines that i mentioned
before
so we have compared the performance of
alinity
with hybrid capture 2 which is
considered as gold standard
and the sensitivity was assessed
on 68 cn2 plus cases
so these are all women that are above 30
years old
and we can see that alinity correctly
identified
all 68 women with cn2 plus
which corresponds to 100 of clinical
sensitivity
and corresponds to relative sensitivity
of
zero five it also meet the
non-inferiority
criteria of meyer guidelines
and with this we have confirmed the
first requirement
of hpv assays so the clinical
sensitivity
the clinical specificity was assessed
on more than 3000 women that were above
30 years old and the clinical
specificity
of alinity was 92.4
and of hybrid capture 91.9
so a bit lower and that corresponds to
relative specificity of
1.05 it also
meets the non-inferiority criteria it's
so the p-value is below 0.05
and with our cohort we have also shown
that a t meets the requirement regarding
the clinical
specificity so the last requirement
is the performance of alinity
according to intro laboratory and
interlaboratory agreement
the intra-laboratory agreement was
performed
on 550 samples
the third of these samples were
hpv-positive
with hybrid capture two according to the
guidelines
and the samples were tested
approximately
one year apart and we have shown here
that
the overall percentage agreement is
really high it's 96.7
which corresponds to kappa value of 0.92
and we have uh
shown this city values that were
plotted so we were interesting how the
city value corresponds between
uh laboratory when testing samples one
year apart
and we have done that for all the
channels of
alinity and we can see that it
corresponds really nice
there are not much of the outliners
the inter-laboratory agreement was
performed into different laboratories
and also one year apart
the overall agreement was even higher
than inter laboratory it was
98.7 with
kappa value of 0.9
we have also plotted this uh
on graphs and we can see that all
channel
corresponds in two different
laboratories taken
taken one year apart so with this
we have fulfilled the last requirement
of hpv tests that can be used
and we have shown that the alinity
meets the requirements and can be
can be considered as clinically
validated and
used in clinical practice
we have also published this in jcm last
year
so more informations can be found
in in the article so
the next part i would like to present
the comparison
of alinity with cobus 4800
so both of these essays are real-time
pcr based tests
and we have performed similar
analysis that we did for for the hybrid
capture
the numbers are a bit
lower and that is because if you
remember
the cobas were
used only for cohort from the
first screening ground so we have
assessed the clinical sensitivity
in 44 cn2 plus cases
and you can see that both essays
correctly identified
all 44 ss as hpv positive
leading to relative sensitivity of 1
and also p-value below 0.05
meeting the first requirement the
specificity was
assessed on more than 3 000 women
it was 92.9 for kobas
and 92.4 for alinity
um so the relative specificity was
0.99 and it also
met the non-inferiority criteria so
there was
no significantly different
specificity assessed in our study
between cobus
and elinity so furthermore we have also
compared alinity and kobas in
analytical ss
for analytical agreement and we can see
that
overall agreement for high-risk hp
positivity
was 97.9 so really high
and also the type specific agreement for
hiv 16 18 and other high-risk hpv
are all extremely high almost 900
percent
for for all of the channels that we have
analyzed so maybe i would just show here
that
um this was performed in the way that
the channel a b and 45 were considered
identical as the channel other uh
other high risk from kobas
so one could argue here that the
agreement is
so high because of number of hpv
negative results that we have so
as you can see here more than three
thousand
and eight hundred samples were each were
considered as hvb negative with both
essays so in the next analysis
we have discarded all the hpv negative
and we have conducted only the
analysis for positive agreement for
high-risk hpv
but we can see that there is not a lot
different
differences that we showed the agreement
is still
over 80 percent it's um
almost 90 percent for hpv 16.
it's slightly lower for hpv 18
but the confidence intervals are quite
wide
due to a low number of hpv 18 infections
alone
so with this i would conclude the first
part
of clinical evaluation according to my
organize
and i would like to go beyond the
guidelines that are that
are needed to be met for for the
clinical
uh use and show you a bit
um a bit about
risk for cn2 and cn3 plus in
our cohort so um
i'm gonna talk about two different risks
the first risk is baseline risk
so when i'm gonna talk about baseline
risk we have considered
only the cn2 plus lesions that were
identified
in the first screening round so that
means 68 cn2 plus cases
and when i'm gonna talk about risk
within
three years uh all the cn2
cases that were identified in both
screening rounds
are included in this analysis
so i would like to start this section
for risk stratification according to
negative baseline characteristics so
we have taken all the women that were
above
30 years old and who had normal cytology
and baseline
and we can see that the risk for cn2
plus within
three years for these women is 0.65
which is relatively low however it's
still
15 times higher when compared to hpv
negative result
so women who are hpv negative and
baseline have extremely
low risk for development of cn2 plus
lesion
and this risk is
comparable between all the hpv essays
that were
used for our cohort we have
also done the sub analysis for
co-testing
and we can see that the code testing in
our cohort
didn't add a lot value compared to hiv
testing alone
and the the when we
take the risk certification according to
positive baseline characteristics so we
have taken all
women that were hpv positive
and you can see as expected here the
highest
risk have women who are hvv
16 positive or hv 16
or 18 positive so the green line
is a limited result the yellow one is
real time and the violet is cobus
and you can see that the risk are
is very comparable between these three
tests
uh what i would like to draw your
attention here
is the difference for alinity a
and b gen channel so we can see that
women
have high so that women that are
positive for
channel a have higher risk than those
who are positive for channel b and this
is even
statistically significant if we take um
into the consideration the longitudinal
component
of our study so the baseline risk
within three years for women that
are positive for hiv types included in
the channel a
is very much higher than those who are
positive
only for hpv types that are included in
channel b
we have done the same for risk
for cn3 plus and
the pictures are really similar
except uh 95 confidence intervals are
wider here
that is due to the lower number of cn3
plus cases
identified in our study however the
difference is still very
can be very nicely seen so it's the
highest for
hpv-16 that is also
of course in accordance to many other
studies that have shown that
women who are hv 16 and 18
positive have the higher risk for cn3
plus
maybe it can be more clearly seen
in in the next few slides so what we
have done here we have divided
women according to the alienated results
into five
groups so in the first group high risk
hbv we have all the women that
are hpv positive regardless of the hpv
types
in non-available hpv group
we have included only hpv types
that are also included in the
non-available vaccine
the next group is hv16 or 18 positive
and then other a channel and other b
channel of the alinity
and here the risk certification is even
more
nicely shown so what is concerning that
one out of five women that have hpv
16 or hv18 infection
also have an underlying cn2 plus
so this means that all the women that
are hv16 or 18 positive
do require immediate coposcopy
but what i wanted to show here as well
is that
one out of 11 11 women of
that are positive for alinity a channel
have underlying cn2 plus
in comparison to one out of 40
um women that are positive for other
b channel of valinity alone
also if we consider the
cn2 plus within three years so
the numbers are even worse for for women
one out of three are gonna develop cn2
plus
in the next three years uh in comparison
to one of the five if there are only hpv
positive
similar is for the cn3 plus
so in our study one out of nine women
that were positive for hpv 16 or 18
had underlying cn3 plus lesion
and um if again
we take into the consideration the
difference between the channel
a and channel b we can see that this is
four times lower between
between these two channels
and again within three years we can see
that
only one out of 35 women
that is positive for other b channel
alone will develop cn3 plus
within the next three years
so what we have constructed here we have
constructed the
theoretic the theoretical pathway
of women through hpv primary screening
according to our results of our study
and as you can see here the most of the
women
are going to be hpv negative and they're
going to be
returned to the next screening round
and the number of hpv negative women
according to
kobus or alinity result are is basically
the same
it's not statistically significant um
about a little more than 10 percent of
women
were considered as hpv positive
and again this this is uh very similar
for kobas and alinity and this group
we have divided on three subgroups
according to their risk and
the the first group is the group that
have immediate risk of cn2 plus
above five percent so for this
certification
we have used the threshold according to
2012
asccp clinical guidelines
and so women who have this risk above
five percent
require immediate colonoscopy so
these women are those who were positive
for hiv 16 and 18
and so the p value between cobus and
elinity
is above 0.05 so that means that
there is no statistically significant
difference between the number of
women that would be referred to
immediate colposcopy
so the second subgroup is those women
who have
immediate risk of cin3 plus between two
and five percent and we can see that
number of women that have this width
is 378 using cobas
and more than half less when using
alinity
so only women that were positive that
were positive for
hpv 45 or channel a
are where uh
were put into this group and the p
value is below 0.05 so that means
that statistically significant less
women
would be referred to six to 12 months
follow-up compared when compared to
linnety with kobas so interestingly we
have
found that women that were
positive for other b and a please note
that we are
talking here for women that are above 30
years old so
their risk of cn3 plus is below to
two percent which means that they can be
returned to
screening round and again we can see
that
there is a difference between number of
women that would be
returned to screening and with this we
could also
lower the number of women that would
have to return
to to six to 12 months follow-up visit
so with this i would conclude the
results from
our cohort and i'm going to present the
last part of my talk and that is the
clinical performance of alinity
invulgent framework so as you know
valjean was initiated in 2012
it's basically a framework
that allows the comparison and
validation
of hpv essays with different
genotyping capability and
so far four vijan frameworks
were performed and today we're going to
focus on biogen3
that was performed on slovenian samples
and we have included 14
different hpv essays in valgen 3.
here is the list of hpv essays that were
evaluated in violent 3
and we're going to focus today on
performance
of limiting so
first just a few words on sample
selection
in vijan framework so according to the
protocol
we have included 1300
women from screening program
and this was enriched with 300 women
that were
diagnosed with either auscus lc
or hysil so of these
seven were excluded from the further
analysis due to the invalid internal
control
and a total of 100 and 593 samples were
included in the final analysis so
clinical sensitivity
was assessed on 126
cn2 plus cases while the clinical
specificity
was assessed on 1212
controls as controls
we have only considered those women who
had
two consecutive negative cytology
results
so we are so that we we make sure that
women are really
can are without disease so
as f as far as the performance of
linearity
in comparison to hybrid capture we have
shown here in this table so we have
divided the analysis in two groups
uh four women older than 30 years old
and then the total study population
so basically regardless of the
population we can see that alinity
showed higher sensitivity and
specificity
compared to hybrid capture 2 it was
1.03 for cn2 plus
and cm3 plus and the specificity was
1.05101.01
so it's higher when compared to hybrid
capture
also the non-inferiority criteria was
met for both specificity and
sensitivity and the similar results are
for total study population
we have performed the same analysis
using cobus 4800 as standard comparator
and in vulgent the sensitivity
of valinity was higher than that of
cobas
with 1.02 for
cn2 plus and also for the cin3plus
we have also shown that the specificity
is the same
for cobus analinity invalgend
and it's it meets the non-inferiority
criteria when compared to kobas
so we have also checked the genotyping
agreement between elinity and cobus so
as i mentioned both of this test
enables the partial hpv-16 genotyping
and we can see that concordance assessed
on
almost 100 and 600 samples
is very high for any hpv type
detected so it's 97.6 which corresponds
to kappa value
of 0.93 and
it's almost 100 percent for hpv
16 with a kappa value of 0.97
so we were also interested since both of
this time
both of these essays are real-time
essays what
what happens to city values
and we have plotted here the city values
for
hpv 16 channel of cobus and ovalinity
and we it so it's clear that
it corresponds really nicely between
these two
essays we have very few outliners
and so we have concluded that genotyping
correlation
is is really good for for hiv 16 channel
we have performed the same analysis for
hpv 18 which is of again
really high almost 100 percent
uh with kappa 0.93
we have again plotted this in this graph
and we can see again that the city
values
corresponds between these two tests very
very nicely
and a special sub analysis was performed
for
hpv-16 and or 18
infection and was again really high
so we have concluded that the
performance
of alinity corresponds really nicely
with the performance of
cubase in valgent iii
so this brings me to my conclusions
of these lectures so we have shown that
the clinical
sensitivity and specificity of valinity
were
non-inferior to those of hybrid capture
we have also shown that the clinical
sensitivity and specificity of
alinity were non-inferior to those of
cobas
in our study our inter-laboratory
and inter-laboratory reproducibility
show
high overall percent percent agreement
which suggests that alumni has very
robust
and reliable performance and with that
said
we have concluded that alunity fulfills
the international assessors guideline
requirements
and can be considered clinically
validated for
hpv primary cervical cancer screening
next we have shown that in sleuvenian
hbo prevalence study
the overall and type specific high-risk
hpv genotyping agreement
between the alinity and cobus was
excellent for
all the common hiv types so all the
kappa values were above 0.8
uh we have also shown in the risk
certification that
women that are older than 30 years
and who are hpv uh limited negative
had lower risk for cn2 plus within the
next three years
than those who have normal baseline
cytology
and that this risk is comparable to that
determined by
real-time hybrid capture or cobus
we have also shown that hv16 infection
was associated with significantly higher
baseline and also
within the year risk for cn2 plus
and cn3 plus and that women who are
hv 16 and 18 they require immediate
colposcopy
but we have also found that found out
that women
who are positive for channel a
and channel b exhibited remarkably
different
risks for cn2 plus and cn3 plus
which lead to the statistically
significant difference
in number of women that would need to
return
to 6 to 12 months follow up with it
if extended limited genotyping
would be used as a triage in hpv primary
screening so i would like to thank
all the people that participated in our
study
uh if the study wouldn't be possible
without them
and i would really like to thank them
yes and with this i will conclude my
lecture
and will happy to answer
any of your questions if you have
thank you anya for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay let's go ahead and get started your
first question is
can you explain the difference between
hpv
16 and hpv 18.
uh sure so uh these are the
two most common uh hpv genotypes
uh so together they cause about 70
of cervical cancer uh
hpv 16 and is associated with the
highest risk
for development of pre-cancerous lesions
and cancer
and when the so
when the genotyping started as possible
triage methods
these two genotypes were between
most wanted target targets in
the screening
great thank you now hybrid capture
is an older method to compare against
what other methods should be used for
comparison
that meets the international guidelines
well according to guidelines
that are currently accepted only
two standard comparators are
uh available one is the hybrid capture
two and the other one is
gp5 plus 6 plus
but we are hoping that
we will we will soon get some new
comparators and
between those that are um associated or
those that are currently on the market
uh probably all assets that fulfills
clinical um so clinical
guidelines for for use in primary
cervical screening
could be in
could be considered as a standard
comparator
most probably uh kobas roche
will be is one of the
most so most likely
uh but there are also several others um
so uh the about real-time uh test
uh or bd or um so
all of the tests that are currently very
widely used in
in the screening
thank you now can you tell us which
age group has the highest hpv cancer
uh yeah well
mostly in uh um so in women that are
between
45 and more but
it differs between the countries
and uh and mostly it depends
on the screening that is available in in
the country so
in the countries that do do not have
organized cervical screening or
where the the
so the coverage of the screening is very
low or
not accessible to women this is also
uh in in younger age groups so in the
less developed countries and the
countries in in in the
with low income uh this also hits women
between
30 and 45 which is
the worst age group for for
[Music]
uh that i mean these are the age groups
that are
very uh that could be prevented with
screening
uh so um i would say
that in in the more
more developed countries uh so a
older ages like uh above
45 uh or also
um in the non-responders so these are
the
group of women that do not respond
to um gynecologist invitations
and in the low income and middle income
countries
this shift to younger
age groups so
above 30.
thank you which method do you prefer for
hpv detection
well um personally
i i have no preference i i think that
the
hpv method that is used
in um in screening should be
uh very
uh so automated uh so the hands-on time
should be very we should be set to
minimum
but it also should be very um reliable
and would have to show very good
clinical performance
in in the comparison so i
i don't have a preference about the
specific
hpv method but uh all the tests that
show has shown good clinical performance
and are um that enables
automated and fast hiv detections
are are my favorite
great thank you all right your next
question is
extended genotyping seems to show
clinical relevance for risk
how are you using this information in
your clinical practice
uh well i see in in slovenia
uh we have um so as i mentioned
uh we are at the moment using
conventional psychology as
uh primary screening so hpv
is used uh already as a triage
but we are hoping and
also globally it has
it has been so determined that hpv
genotyping
especially extended genotyping that
means
above hv 16 and 18
is is all a possible
way to go for the triage
so the idea is that we would we would
have hpv
primary screening
and then use the same sample so that
would
that would be very good for also for the
women who are participating in screaming
because
only one visit would be
necessary to to the gynecologist instead
of
two so in in cases
in in cases where women are hpv positive
the information about hiv genotype
would be implemented in the in the flow
chart
so those with the highest risk
so as we have shown in in this lecture
so women with
hv 16 18 and possibly
45 and other a as we have shown here
those those women would be invited to
immediate coposcopy
or those with other a
in a six-month visit while
those who would be positive uh for
channel b
uh could be actually returned to the to
the screening
and they would be checked again
in in three years
without losing any any
cancer detection in in the program
i hope that answers the questions
thank you so much okay it looks like we
have time for one more question
says in your opinion or experience what
is needed to ensure
that hpv primary screening is
implemented
correct and what has been done in
slovenia
well i i would say that the first thing
that
is needed in the organized screening
is the coverage so the coverage for
in order that screening is effective uh
we we need to achieve the coverage above
70 percent
uh at least to to
dramatically reduce the incidence of
cervical cancer
in slovenia as i mentioned we have
very high coverage rates in national
screening program and we are very happy
about it
the plan is um we are
conducting a pilot study at the moment
in slovenia and um so the first uh
step uh that we will try to achieve is
the
implementation of liquid-based
technology
and then this is
we are still deciding how to proceed
uh either we're gonna
go with the primary
cytology for women that
are younger and then above 35
hpv testing um
and we still haven't um we are still
um testing and
uh trying to decide what would be the
best uh triage method
for for our country
thank you again anya do you have any
final comments for our audience
before we go today
um well um i would just like to thank
them for
for their intention and if you if they
have any
uh additional questions or um i am
available
at my email um
anya dot austrian um
and they can send the questions
thank you so much and it looks like we
had one more question come in
snack right in here if you don't mind
let's go ahead and try and answer this
one before we go today
it says why is hpv
thank you it says why is hpv
16 and 18 um riskier
in comparison with hpv 31
56 59 etc
well all the hv genotypes
that we know and at the moment we have
more than
200 and uh hiv genotypes
that are um uh
so that are recognized uh and
but uh the we are still
uh not sure about why
some of the risks some of the hp
genotypes are associated with the higher
risk for
development of cn2 plus
um but
probably i probably there is uh
some sort of uh different um
like um the the virus has different
uh how to put that so uh
it um when it's integrated in the
in the genome um it looks like the
hpv types that are that are associated
with the higher risk
are are more um aggressive and
in they they are causing the
the underlying lesions
most so
more times than than the other hpv
genotypes but there are some uh
studies available that are trying to
um to to see the underlying mechanisms
for the
uh tropism and and and the
risk that is associated with the
infection
thank you for that and thank you anya
for your time today and for your
research
we would also like to thank libraries
thank you and our sponsor abbott global
scientific affairs
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
and before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their questions questions we did
not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by anya via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
laborats will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye